one of the nominees for Best Picture is
three billboards outside Epping Missouri
yeah I gotta say it's a divisive film
some people loved it other people hated
it but everyone does agree on one thing
they all agree that the best part of the
movie is the billboard races wait
there weren't any billboard races in
that movie of course there were Andy
it's the most exciting part of the film
yeah check out this book from the movie
I start up a database and as soon as he
done something wrong
cross-reference it make a hundred
percent certain it was a correct match
then kill him yeah well there's
definitely civil rights laws prevents
that I'm doing everything I can to track
him down I don't think those billboards
is very fair
[Applause]
that's just stupid
you know another film that got some
Oscar nominations is all the money in
the world Christopher Plummer was
nominated for his performance in this
film now here's where it gets weird his
role was controversial because Plummer
replaced Kevin Spacey after the film was
already completed and this was
accomplished through some very quick
reshoots and a little bit of CGI now
it's amazing that Plummer pulled off an
oscar-worthy performance under those
conditions but it's kind of hard to
watch the movie without looking for
places with a digitally inserted plumber
into the film it took me out of it a bit
see if you can spot any in this scene
they will do things to Paul that cannot
be undone for any amount of money we
have to paint this simple isn't possible
my financial position has changed boil
up as much as it was this morning you
have amassed another fortune I have
never been more vulnerable financially
if all due respect nobody has ever been
richer than you are at this moment
spare and what would it take for you to
feel secure
[Applause]
you